anh
alo cho mọi người ạ
khi mùa đông lạnh giá
tự nhiên nhắc Thế lại muốn mở bài viết
trẻ bây giờ tôi mở nhạc bài đấy Không
biết bao giờ nhăn bản quyền không
Ok thì
hôm nay mình đầu tiên thì mình system sự
đã tranh thủ 5 phút tâm sự của bữa hôm
trước còn chưa tâm sự
sau đó đến mình sẽ che lại trả lời các
câu hỏi rồi cùng mà mình mới lại cốt ông
ạ hoặc là cái câu hỏi này đi buổi sau
nữa trả lời để hôm nay chỉ ngồi tập
trung like tốt bởi vì mình nghĩ rằng là
trong mong tiếng ấy mình sợ đâu không đủ
thời gian để mình ở cốt kết hợp với việc
cả chấm Có khi cố tình không đủ gian
3G mình mình trữ lượng được nó sẽ như
thế nào
Nghe có vẻ nhẹ có thể sẽ nhanh có thể
dựa chậm lập trình viên mình không bao
giờ không bao giờ nên được bị gọi là chủ
quan quá lúc nào nghĩ rằng nào ngồi các
bạn hàng ngang tầm 10 20 phút là xong
rồi cùng mình ngồi test cùng các hư chứ
kiểu giày này mấy ngày hiểm chưa xong
mình bị thêm mấy phá rồi nên bây giờ
mình sẽ không hứa được là bao giờ có
được xong một cái gì đó Sếp nói cái bà
lắm Em vẫn đang làm
theo tôi có thể mình nghĩ sắp xong rồi
nhưng mà vẫn bảo em vẫn đang làm không
ngờ nói sắp xong không làm sếp thất vọng
sẽ phải trừ lương người lắm
những cái ông mà bảo là em sắp xong rồi
lại dành cho nửa tiếng một tiếng nữa vẫn
chưa xong à
Ok nói chung và bây giờ Tâm sự tí thì
hôm trước có bạn hỏi và đưa mình cũng
nghĩ việc đấy rồi trước khi bạn hãy hỏi
luôn đó là về khái niệm đi chơi này Ừ
thì thực ra thì mình à
à à
Và tất nhiên là mình làm con người hiểu
dạng mà
không thích hòa hẳn vào đám đông lắm Có
lúc thì mình thích hòa và truyền hình
giống như là đi Cao des Heineken
đếm ngược để mà xem pháo hoa Kì ạ Nếu mà
vắng tanh thì nó nhạt nhẽo đông đông
người ra nóng mới có không khí trong
trường hợp mà kiểu quẩy như thế thì mình
nghĩ phải càng đông càng vui nhưng mà
còn những cái dịp khác thì mình không
thích kiểu chen chúc vào những cái đấy
và bìa mua dịch này cháu bảo muốn chen
vào cả cờ thế nhiều người vẫn tranh thủ
đi nhưng mình thì không Tại sao phải
tranh thủ của vì với mình có đi học đi
Ngày lễ này bất kỳ ngày có dịp gì đó Hồi
trước mình toàn mới kì gì kể cả
ngày thương binh liệt sĩ mình cũng đó
này không còn nét cơ
kiểu thế Ô kìa
hiện nay lễ Tết đấy thì tội thương tích
ở nhà là sinh nhật tôi còn ở nhà
ý nghĩa đàn chỉ là
những ngành khác tôi có thể sẽ đi chơi
bù và những người khác nếu là thực sự
muốn đi nhưng mà còn những ngày đấy tôi
sẽ không Đâm đầu à trừ khi là nó có hằn
phải sự kiện gì đó bấm đi tôi và bạc là
nó chỉ tổ chức một ngày hôm đấy Nhưng
nếu mà tôi thích cái đây Quá thử sẽ đi
ông ạ
Ờ Ờ Bây giờ tôi khoe một tí nhé Có ông
tiên nó hỏi của tôi ghê Đúng không Tôi
đang dùng ngồi ghế Công Thái Học ở các
bạn Trà bây giờ sẽ thấy công nghệ game
mình rửa lỗi thời rồi Bây giờ thời đại
của Ghế Công Thái Học Vui nữa tốt xương
sống và Vân nó ngoại và tôi không tự mua
đâu đầu tiên thu tự mua con Gaming từ
thời từ hồi mới đi làm
Mẹ mua cho Đấy là tôi vẫn giữ lên bây
giờ cho đến khi sếp thấy làm việc tại
nhà càng quá dịch căng quá và và xếp
muốn kiểu dạng mà động viên anh em anh
em lập trình viên ở công ty tôi công ty
pháp mà nhà mà các sếp đều rất là giàu
em biết sếp tôi thưởng gì không tặng mỗi
một con ghế cẩm phải học Xếp bảo là mỗi
con trị giá 1 Nino ship từ Mỹ về không
biết tại sao phải xin đừng nghĩ vậy bây
giờ bán ở Việt Nam rất nhiều nhờ thôi mà
tôi chả biết giá dưới 1.000 đô không
Nhưng mà tôi thấy rất xanh trai à
có giá rẻ hơn 10 ghế bình thường Có thể
cho đầy đủ chân đầy đủ tất cả chức năng
mới Chứ có cả là đã lưng giống như kiểu
nằm được luôn và có chỗ để chân Vân về
câu nói Học thật sự tôi ngồi xong tôi
không muốn ngồi sang ghế kia nữa chờ cái
mùa lạnh này chỉ Công nhận là tôi phải
bắt thêm cái chăn cho nó không thì nó có
cái lỗ lỗ hơn sau ấy buốt Vậy con cái
game minh thì ra là nó còn ra
về liên minh nó ra Kiểu nó bị bong là
không thích và cả nó bí bàn ghế Con này
họ cảm thấy thoải mái hơn rất nhiều ạ
Ừ ok tiếp nha Ờ mình giấy phép tâm sự
xong hết cho thì mình lai cốt Vậy mình
Câu hỏi thì để bữa sau mà trả lời đi Ờ
nó Tiên thì có bạn hỏi về cách đi bốc
Ê bà cách học không phải hỏi cái này tự
mình muốn trả lời đó là đầu tiên thì các
bạn sẽ bây giờ các bạn Làm lập trình
viên rồi Khi mà có hiển thị bất kỳ cái
gì lỗi thì nó nhìn thấy lên các bạn đừng
tắt nó đi ngay cũng như là lập tức kiểu
Ôi cái đoạn này lỗi rồi Sao rồi không
thèm đọc cái sai lỗi để toàn bộ là để
chị lên để cho cho anh em mình đọc để
anh em mình có thể tra Google
tìm và hiểu được cái lỗi đấy ông ạ về
sau chắc là tôi sẽ có hàng Hà cũng lại
chờ chút tiếc để mà nhìn thấy một loạt
lỗi rồi mấy ông Thủy dịch xem lỗi gì hãy
cứ thế Cái này thì ra mà cần đúng là cần
một tí riêng anh như con trọng bằng
tiếng Anh này thế chân này
chứ không phải tiếng Anh cơ bản mà Mấy
ông có thể bắt bẻ cả em giúp tiếng Anh
đúng không ạ
Mấy ông ngồi quen được đọt Lỗ đi hôm
trước của ông chụp cho tôi đúng cái màn
hình Lỗi
cho tôi Tôi nghĩ nghe tôi biết ngay là
lỗi để lỗi gì Tại sao bởi vì ngay từ cái
hồi mà tôi đi học Tôi đã gặp cái lỗi
hàng tùy Zalo thì lần hơi quá Nhưng mà
tôi hỏi thầy rất nhiều lần và
À thầy thầy dạy của tôi hồi đấy thầy có
cách dậy không biết đúng cách dậy không
ngờ cũng mỗi lần thấy dậy xong bài thời
ra bài tập để thấy mất tích luôn mất
tích đến cả rồi đi về cũng mất tích
không thấy đâu nữa
trường tôi được lại vợ lại thấy ở dưới
bà thấy thời gian qua hút thuốc nhé Rồi
rồi từ đây không thấy thể quay lại luôn
Thế nên là bọn nó sẽ ngồi chơi như tôi
từng nói Tôi không ngờ đến trường đi
chơi dậy Ngồi học và khi họp xong thì
tôi sẽ làm hết được bài tập xong rồi tôi
sẽ vui vẻ và nâng cao nhưng mà đương
nhiên là không phải là con nhà người ta
nên là đời lúc gặp những cái lỗi rơi va
vớ vẩn không Không biết ai hỏi nếu là tự
phải mau thế là kỹ năng đi Ba của tôi về
cơ bản cao hơn cái đứa trong lớp mấy đứa
trong lớp gặp lỗi không thấy thầy chuyển
có chơi game coi như là cuộc sống bế tắc
Ừ tôi không như thế ở dễ dạy giải quyết
bằng được thì thôi Về Mái Nhà Chung quy
bóp lắm miếng ngồi chơi game Tôi bảo rồi
nếu không tốn tiền học để cái đấy ngồi
chơi game ngu si chẳng có quán net là
tiền học đắt và tiền nhé tắt như thế cả
số tiền đấy là đi nét rồi gọi tinh mì ăn
phải tốt hơn đâu rồi không
ừ ừ
à à
Ừ rồi Tiếp nha mình nói thêm một cái nữa
Thu Gà cái quán bia cái này về con điểm
của mình họ chẳng liên quan gì cái việc
à lập trình viên anh không
a baby a từng yêu trước lại có một bài
đăng về cái này bà thậm phí à Ờ hồi rước
chính người yêu cũ thôi đã từng hỏi câu
này không biết là ông đã bờ từng gặp cái
trường hợp bị hỏi câu này chưa Nếu mà
ông bị hỏi rồi thì thử xem không trả lời
ngay nhé
đương nhiên Thì hồi trước thì tôi có
quan niệm về
áo
kiểu cưới rồi mới làm chuyện ấy ở
nhà thuốc bắt điểm cái đấy nói Dung à
tôi giữ em yêu nói chung không phải giữ
người yêu mà cả hai cùng cậu này luôn là
giờ đừng đoán cái thứ sau đó hơn 15 kiểu
hình Như Hóc Môn mà còn lên cao quá rồi
nói chung Thực ra mấy ông mà chỉ cần hôn
nhau trong thôi Khi mà cái tầm tuổi dậy
đi Cái gì ông cũng
lại tay đụng chạm các thứ thôi cùng thì
đương nhiên à Ờ
có chuyện gì đấy nó sẽ đến
Ừ tôi không giấu cái đấy xảy ra là
Ừ cái đấy thì ra bây giờ mình lớn rồi
đã có nhiều người có khi ở đây cũng làm
rồi đó chứ trên tôi làm gì
ờ ờ
anh nói chung là Rồi rồi sau đó được như
là không không không có tôi tôi chưa
từng có con luôn nhá nói thế vậy đừng
quá lo giờ tôi có con Hạnh tôi bên anh
sẽ giác đâu nhé Xin lỗi à Nói chung à
ờ ờ ờ
và đương nhiên thì làm một lần ông còn
nghĩ là ông sẽ làm đợt 20 sẽ chẳng nó sẽ
có đúng không ạ chính như lần này giờ
thế bởi vì một phần nhà bạn đấy cũng khá
gần nhà tôi nên kiểu ngày nào đi chơi
với nhau rồi qua nhà nhau thoải mái
22 nhà gia đình hai bên với nhau của đời
tôi thích cưới bạn ấy cơ Nếu mà yêu thêm
khoảng thời gian nữa khi tôi cưới Hồi
đấy tôi mới
năm nhất đại học à
anh nói chung nhà tôi vì sau bạn ấy chả
hiểu đọc từ đâu Mẹ hỏi tôi con này đó là
Anh Em có thai rồi
Ừ anh tính sao Anh muốn nuôi hai à Bỏ
anh em ốm thì trả lời tôi coi mày khi mà
năm nhất đại học Nếu trả lời tôi đi
em yêu sớm thế á không mấy ông đều phải
có
tình yêu tuổi học trò cấp 3 cấp 3 ngày
không đi từ khi em không có lần đầu tiên
được nên làm ở chỗ nhà
cấp 3 có đại học cũng cũng lên đúng
không ạ đi
ở đây đây đây để để để tôi để tôi nói
cho mấy ông cái này tôi đang nói theo
quan điểm của tôi có thể nhiều người sẽ
khó chịu với vấn đề này bởi vì tôi thấy
đều bị ông đều đang nói ạ
khi nuôi mặc không tôi tôi sẽ không nuôi
Hồi đấy tôi đã nói thằng bạn đấy tôi sẽ
không Tôi sẽ không muốn dự giữ bởi vì từ
các bạn mới bãi bỏ mới kiểm tra ờ
ở tại Tại sao tại sao lại không nuôi bởi
vì ra làm thằng năm nhất nó chưa có cái
gì cả
Ừ thì không không thể không thể bỏ cả sự
nghiệp tương lai tới thứ và và cũng như
là nói chung là Kiều thực ra ông mà lúc
này có con thì mọi thừa sẽ khác hoàn
toàn không không không khó đi học thơ
này không phải đi làm cái thứ thứ hai
đúng ạ ạ
Ồ không tôi lúc đấy tôi sẽ chọn nó không
đưa nhà tôi không nói là bỏ bạn đấy Thôi
tôi chỉ và tôi sẽ đưa bạn đấy đi theo ra
không cần
lúc đấy phải đứa đi lúc lúc đấy hình như
là
anh không có uống thuốc được không biết
được lúc nào cũng đưa không như là lần
này tôi phải sẽ đưa đi
không đúng là chủ đề này rất nhạy cảm
nhưng tôi đang muốn nói chưa có điểm là
Ừ cái này nghe có về à Nhờ bạn mình sẽ
kiểu muốn
em muốn nghĩ rằng là ở kiểu phải nuôi
rồi các thứ phải chịu trách nhiệm cái
cái cái từ chịu trách nhiệm nó khác hơn
là bỏ thí nghiệm nhé Chị nghiện đây ám
chỉ là sẽ đưa đi đi
một là khi mà mình có tài chính khi mình
có sự nhiệt thì mình sẽ nhận nuôi À nhận
anh nhận nuôi và kiểu nói chuyện rất
bình thường nhưng khi ở các bạn Đang tầm
tuổi đấy ra các bạn đều đang nông nổi
anh không khoa học khái niệm đấy rất là
nông nổi Khi mà mình muốn nuôi một đứa
như thế
ở tầm tuổi này vẫn ở rất là kiểu còn
chưa lo cho bản thân
Ừ nếu vậy hiểu là như thế mười chín tuổi
mày ông đã tự kiếm tiền để nuôi bản thân
còn khó Bây giờ ông còn nuôi nuôi cả gia
đình nữa đi
Chú mèo bị đùa thôi à nó ngon không tôi
không nói tôi sẽ bỏ đấy Hai cái gì cả
không về kiểu Vứt cái cục tiền và bạn ấy
tự đi Cái gì đó không Tôi bà sẽ Cậu đưa
vậy đi Nói chung là đi đánh nhưng mà
mình không thể nuôi được tầm tầm đấy
Đúng hồi cái này cái quan điểm này nhá
quan điểm này còn ở bên Tây nữa này Thế
là tôi đang phải nói cái này nhá điểm
lên đây nó là
Nếu giả sử mà được bé mà nó con bị dị
dạng hay bị yếu vân vân các tự tử
khi đôi khi ở các bạn Giết nó nó vẫn còn
một sự nhân từ hơn khi mà các bạn nuôi
nó xong mà nó phải sống hoàn cảnh như
thế à
Ê mấy ông phải hiểu khái niệm là thận
chế là nhiều nhiều con gái giờ thích
kiểu khái niệm mẹ đơn thân như kiểu là
nếu mà giờ sử mà anh ấy bỏ tôi Một khi
tôi có thai Tôi vẫn sẽ muốn đẻ và nuôi
được đấy một mình mà nghĩ ra nhà riết nó
khi mà
đi Giết nó khi mà nó kiểu nói chung là
nó đã là một sinh linh ấy nếu không Linh
riết rồi đấy Cái này thì đúng nếu mà nó
vẫn sai điểm là
à à
Ừ nó vẫn sai thời điểm là
nếu nếu mà giờ sử mà các bạn nuôi nó một
mình nó sẽ bị thiếu tình cảm của người
người cha cả nặng ạ
Ừ cái này tôi sẵn nói ra được bởi vì sao
Bởi vì chính thôi à Không phải là không
phải là bố đâu bỏ bỏ mẹ tôi mà là nói
chung là bố tôi bị mất từ bé thế là mẹ
tôi cũng mẹ đơn thân
và phải phải có phải đóng cả hai vai trò
cả cả bố cả mẹ để nuôi nướng tôi mà tôi
từng nói là cái gia đình nhà tôi thì rất
quan trọng với tiền bạc thì ra chẳng ai
chẳng ai cũng giúp đỡ gì cả mẹ tôi hồi
đấy rõ khổ bà mẹ rồi còn bị lâm bệnh nữa
bởi vì kiểu phải gồng Gánh Cả hai cái
ông thường nghĩ việc vai trò của vừa
phải kiếm tiền vừa phải làm việc nhà vừa
phải nuôi con đi
anh nói chung là tôi bị thiếu thiệt hồn
tình cảm của người bố và mẹ tôi phải
thay thế đấy nhiều người mẹ khác thì tôi
không nghĩa có thể làm được điều đấy
thế nên tôi nghĩ là về cái quan điểm
em về con điểm mà Nhiều người nghĩ ra
kiểu khi mà có thai thì nên phải bắt
buộc phải đẻ và phải
có phải như nào là tôi không khuyên về
việc là mấy ông cứ cứ làm chuyện đấy A B
C z đi xong rồi phá cái đấy được cái đấy
Tôi không kiên như thế là tôi đang tôi
đã nói theo cái quan điểm khác
Ừ em ăn nhưng mà trong trường hợp của
tôi thì thì
trong trường hợp vừa nãy tôi vẫn yêu cũ
thì đúng là bạn đấy hỏi câu đấy cốt là
kiểu để tránh để xem tôi con người nhà
thôi cứ được là bạn ấy không có gì cả
anh Bởi vì à tôi tặng chơi ba hết mà
nghe không Không có gì cả nhưng mà bạn
đấy Trì kiểu bạn ơi lấy cái ảnh trên
Google không hiểu ảnh 2 vạch cho ngồi
bạn gửi cho tôi bạn nói thế
Ừ thì thờ cái mình mình nghe thấy mình
không nghĩ gì cả Mình thấy cái ảnh của
mình mình cũng kiểu mình nghĩ là cậu
đã lỡ rồi nhưng mà mình vẫn phải chịu
trách nhiệm rất nhiều cái ngoạn mình vẫn
chịu trách nhiện nhưng mà không phải
chịu trách nhiệm mà cũng chỉ ra phải đẻ
Hướng nuôi mấy ông cứ thử nghĩ là khi mà
khi mà thế thì sẽ hiểu cuộc đời của tôi
là sẽ thả nó sẽ hướng như nào đúng ạ ra
nhiều thứ mình chưa là
Ê mấy ông đừng có nghĩ về việc là cứ có
tiền là có thể nên để con có sự nghiệp
như này con cái việc theo ca để con bây
giờ ấy
rất nhiều người đẻ con ra mới bắt đầu
học có trách nhiệm thực ra thấy hơi say
Em làm thế ảnh hưởng đứa con rất nhiều
anh không biết mình không quan điểm mày
nào nhưng mà mục khi là tôi có con
Ừ tôi phải chắc chắn nó là một đứa một
kiểu được sinh ra một trong môi trường
rất tốt và kiểu được chăm sóc tử tế Thế
nên nhiều người khuyên tôi đưa lên cưới
hay các từ thứ thì cảm ơn gấu của cưới
chăng nữa tôi sẽ không có con sớm tôi sẽ
phải chắc chắn
các bạn đấy ạ Bạn ấy đương nhiên cưới
khác không thấy có một đứa một đứa hai
đứa không ở đó à
anh nói chung là tôi vừa rồi nói tâm sự
với một cái chủ đề giữa ngay cả nếu mà
tôi là một người từng trải và cũng như
là
cũng có mua Tuổi Thơ nó cũng thiếu thốn
em không cần phải dùng từ nghèo hay khô
Tình Nghèo Có không phải nghèo thì không
đi có con lắm chỉ phải có trách nhiệm
nữa và nói chung à Phải
phải có một cái gì đó đúng ạ Chứ không
phải là không có gì trong tay hứng lên
là đẹp thế thì cậu bé vô tâm người con
mình không ạ
Ừ tôi không nói gia đình tôi vô tâm
người có bởi Chính mẹ tôi ở người hi
sinh thì tôi rất nhiều bạn nhưng mà vì
chỉ có một người hi sinh bị thiếu đi một
người ngân hàng ra là kiểu nó sẽ vẫn còn
không trọn vẹn nó không đầy đủ rồi không
có là đủ được Nếu không hiểu được cái
điện mày đâu đúng không ạ
Ờ Ờ
nói chung là thực ra cũng có người ở đây
cũng biết thôi Tôi không biết là gia
đình mỗi người một cái gì đó một hoàn
cảnh riêng không ai khổ quá Không ai
sướng quá hơn ai cả à
à à
gà mấy bạn đang quan điểm để tiền thì ta
là tôi tôi thì biết rồi đúng à tôi xuống
đây không để chuyển tiền nhưng mà thực
ra là
cái tiền nó vẫn chỉ là cái thứ đứng sau
rất nhiều cái thôi chúng ta phải có
trách nhiệm phải kéo bây giờ giả sử
không có tiền đi không ạ nhưng đừng gái
bảo cưới thì một người có chí thì người
ta làm sẽ viết thích có một người mà
không phải trí từ các có bao nhiêu tiền
cũng không mở đủ không ạ hãy sẽ ra nó là
thế thôi I
Ừ đúng rồi lại kêu là đúng không ạ ạ
i took a từ bàn tay mình gở Đông ạ Quan
trọng mình muốn làm hay không mà ni sinh
hay không đúng ạ là sửa dạng như là hồi
trước mình thường hay xem những cái nó
đơn giản về người bố kiểu hệ sinh khắp
nơi bố kiểu nghiện chơi bời Này nghiện
cờ bạc này nhiệm đối với Đôi khi chỉ đơn
giản là nhận hút thuốc ôi đường ạ đúng ạ
hiện kiểu ra một ngày chỉ có một hai đứa
thôi nhưng từ khi có con không uống 10
và hút thêm một cái đĩa Còn nữa không
ngờ uống thêm một cốc rượu nữa đúng
không ạ Đấy là một vị một sự hi sinh ở
đấy đúng ạ Nó không cần gì phải quá to
part cả nhưng mà nói cho mày chắc rằng
khi mà khi mà kiểu sinh con ra mà mình
không thay đổi mình không trưởng thành
hơn không ạ
thì thì nó Nó là kiểu dạng là
Ừ nó nó không
vì nó không còn gọi là trắc nghiệm bình
thường đã ạ
Ừ
Ok À mà nuốt vào nút Cái này hơi hơi dài
dòng qua những xin phép là nốt Thực ra
đi ỉa
em có bạn vậy cũng vừa nói đó là bạn hỏi
là người yêu cũ thế nào và tôi chở được
bởi vì thật là
tôi thường anh xem này năm năm trước tôi
thường hay xem những người từng lại bình
luận hay thích những cái bài đấy và
đương nhiên đôi khi dính cả người cũ ở
trong đấy
và đứng nghĩa là mấy ông mà thấy người
yêu cũ như ông có bấm vào tôi có biết
mấy ông như thế nào nhưng mà hồi trước
tôi từng chặng Nếu cũ thì chắc là tôi
không nhìn thấy nữa mùa khi mỗi lỡ thấy
rồi Chắc là nó Mình sẽ bấm vào xem mà
kiểu họ người đấy Bây giờ đang sống thế
nào Nóng ạ Có ổn không khi không còn ở
bên mình đúng ạ Đấy thì về cơ bản đi họ
đầy hơi buồn
cười kiểu em tốt hơn khi mà rời xa anh
ấy đấy thì thực ra thì
và cũng chính thì cái nỗi buồn đấy theo
kiểu dạng là không có mình Họ sống tốt
hơn hay thậm chí là người yêu quý ông
mới nhiều mới của em đầy có ôtô nhạ chút
gì là tôi không ở nhà thôi không có cái
gì cả Nói chỗ ở về cơ bản thì tôi bàn
tay trắng luôn toàn bộ những thứ tôi
đang có đây nó tiêu sản nhưng mà tại sao
anh chưa Thế
đấy là một cái
có động lực
Ừ để mà mình phải phấn đấu thực ra tính
trước tính từ trước đến nay thừa Tôi
ghét mua nhà đã làm vé mua ôtô lắm nhưng
bây là tự nhiên nhìn thấy em lấy kiểu
nắm tay thằng khác ở trong cái ô tô ở đó
rồi bà yêu anh Viber vật ông nghe con
nói xong nó kiểu
Ừ nó kiểu bị cái tôi của tôi nó sẽ rất
lớn nên là tôi sẽ nghĩ rằng là
tôi sẽ phấn đấu Dĩ nhiên là vợ tôi vẫn
ghét ô tô ít nhớ là tôi ghét ô tô ở Hà
Nội với cái Hạnh đường Hà Nội bé tí Nếu
cố giúp cái ô tô cùng tắc đường nữa khó
chịu được đấy nhưng mà tôi sẽ cất nhắc
về cái vụ là
em dậy phải cố Hơn nữa để cho em thấy
không hả nuối tiếc đâu em đấy con còn
bận tâm thì mình đâu Đúng ngoại nhưng mà
nói chung là mình sẽ phải có một cái gì
đó để mình
tôi hãy hạnh đôi khi mấy ông chỉ cần
nghĩ đơn giản như tôi đang nghĩ bây giờ
đó là à
Ê thằng thằng khác làm cho em hạnh phúc
Ok thì bây giờ mình sẽ làm người yêu
mình còn hạnh phúc hơn cả thằng kia là
anh kiểu thế chúng ta cùng khi khi giảm
béo hạnh phúc hơn ít nhất như thế
em
yêu cũ chạm hả ông ăn ở thế nào cho ông
thường hay thả và Thả tim hay sạc Ấn Độ
đúng không ạ
à à
anh Lương 100 cụ một tháng không lương
100 cùng mà ông quan điểm cái cái việc
lương cao ấy
ta lương cao bằng miệng phải tiêu nhiều
mình không rồi à
I I'm tất cả tao khuyên mày ông nữa đó
là thực ra là mình không phải bị
em phải quen dần việc là
không để bị cái
là cây gì nhỉ à
Ừ cái quan điểm của xã hội áp tạm lên
bản thân mình
Ừ quan điểm dùng thử quan điểm tạm được
đó là như thế nào Ví dụ là sự như là
đương nhiên tôi không nói mấy ông phải
vi phạm luật phát theo kiểu lại ừ thì 10
tuổi yêu nhau do ngồi cửa nhá Nó như vẫn
phải theo luật pháp nghe nó nói là không
phải đến 10 đến đủ tuổi cứ thì ông cưới
luôn kiểu như thế không phải đến đủ tuổi
là ông nên phải như nào đấy như thế nào
đấy chèo 20 tuổi mà không phải yêu 25
tuổi ông phải cưới 30 tuổi cũng phải có
nhà có sẽ không Nếu không đừng để mày
điều đấy xảy ra nếu ông nhưng giờ mới
chính mình nếu không thích cái gì là sửa
ông thích độc thân Ok đúng như là thời
ra tôi không khuyên là tất cả mọi người
cùng lên độc thân thế thì xã hội này sẽ
đi về đâu đúng không ạ Nhưng chắc chắn
có người này người kia rồi nhưng mà Cái
quan trọng là mấy ông hãy sống với chứng
minh nếu không cần phải yêu khi mà thấy
bạn bè xung quanh đều có người yêu
anh đúng không ạ ạ
Ừ Ok đợi nói nói nốt ruồi nốt một tí bởi
vì thật ra cái gì đấy
nhiều người ở đây vẫn còn đang bị kéo
nhiều người xung quanh nói thành nó cũng
bị tác động ấy à
ở đây tôi tôi khuyên mày ông như thế
Mình không cần phải kiểu cứ theo làm đâu
còn gì cả
Ừ Ok Thôi bây giờ bắt đầu không Hôm nay
sẽ thứ ra không hẳn học mà hôm nay mình
sẽ thử sẽ thử chỉ các bạn cách để mà
like cốc thôi
bây giờ tập trung vào học thì cũng sẽ
nhớ đỡ nhớ về cái gì cả
đầu năm sau rezel người ta là không đúng
lắm phải đến khóa tế tâm đi mới có tâm
nên mới bảo vệ Chắc phải đến tháng ba
tháng tư mà có đầu nhảy sáng lao đâu em
bởi vì còn phải học mới xe ôm B đã
vì cuộc sống màu hồng khi yêu làm bạn
kia lại mơ mộng quá rồi xem nhiều phim
tình cảm nó rồi cuộc sống sĩ nó đủ màu
khi yêu
có đủ màu nhẹ nó sẽ thêm màu sắc hỏi cho
nó có thể là không hả làm màu hồng sẽ
đôi khi màu đen màu gì đó rồi nó sẽ đổ
mà không ạ ạ
Ừ
thôi ok Bây giờ thì hôm nay mình sẽ có
cái này em nghỉ sẽ viết cho các bạn xem
hôm nay thì thì mình muốn làm ở đây mình
một mình bảo mình sẽ làm tool này mà
tuần này mà chấm đồ ăn nhanh nhiều ạ Thế
bản chất ở đây mình muốn làm là gì Các
bạn sẽ thấy ở đây mình đang thử thứ nhất
là mình thường ai lên kết hấp của các
bạn chia sẻ đường link sau đó đi ỉa clan
clan kiểu đúng rồi nó gọi Clone về lon
cài vô check về nó sẽ có lần này thư mục
Cốt và Cái quan trọng là
À hôm trước mà mình mới bảo các bạn làm
đa tới đây để mà sau đó xuất ra file
word
Ừ để mình inbox vào để mà chấm
Ừ thì bây giờ mới ông thể nhìn có nhắn
này lần này thư mục
ờ ờ năm nay thư mục mà Bây giờ tôi lại
còn phải không những lại inbox với lại
phải crack đã tới đây bởi vì mấy cái
file này đôi khi là nó không có cả câu
lệnh class nên phải crash database và
kết ra tao bay Tôi còn phải tạo của tạo
ra bay có cùng trùng với cái á
này cho mình xem chung với tệ phải tên
của cái xổ số nhóm đấy ông ạ bởi vì mấy
ông Toàn đặt tên là tao bây giờ là linh
ta linh tinh nên là bây giờ tôi không
muốn làm bạn như thế này tôi sẽ cốt cho
ông kể đoạn này đó là tôi sẽ lấy ở trong
từng cái thư mục này này cái ý tưởng cốt
của tôi như thế này nhá Ở là lấy
em
lấy tất cả
file Wow trong tất cả thư mục
rồi red-letter bay
inbox lần lượt từng
có phải đó vào
từ hạt ông kia chưa xuất file database
hay từ các tý thôi sẽ kiểm tra với từng
nhóm tôi sẽ in ra luôn với từng nhóm nhỉ
có pha yesware mà tìm thấy được trong
ngày nay không Bởi vì thức a tại sao cái
này phải cốt của Vì thời gian mấy ông
thấy thứ nhất là quá nhiều cái việc gì
mà lặp đi lặp lại mà nó quá nhiều thì
chúng ta nên nghĩ việc cốt chúng ta rất
cũng mệt không ạ thứ hai đó là
Ừ Cái quan trọng là rất nhiều ông hứng
đây là sửa đã ta bay có thứ 02 là sửa cơ
sở sửa về cái cấu trúc mà là đôi khi ở
thay đổi cả dữ liệu ở trong trong các
thứ thứ nữa không ạ thì mỗi lần tôi chấm
nữa mấy ông tôi lại phải nhập lại bằng
tay à không đúng không ạ Tôi chỉ cần tại
chạy tool này là xong đúng không ạ Nếu
không hiểu thì thôi ạ ấy thì tốt lại
group data bay đi Sau đó thì lại inbox
lại thì nó thì mày Ông thấy nó sẽ rất là
ngon và rất là ồn nó ngoại đấy đấy thứ
nhất thứ hai đó là nếu thấy có rất nhiều
thư mục trong thư mục này của đôi khi
còn có rất nhiều người thư mục con nữa
mấy ông nhét file word ở đầu đâu đấy Sao
tôi mất công ty những thừa kế giống kiểu
đánh đổi Nên là nên là bây giờ tôi sẽ
làm tôn để mà nó sẽ đọc từng cái thứ mục
ngoài tìm bằng được cái file có đua lẽ
queo Ninh inbox là Ẩm Thực ra cái này có
nhược điểm nữa thì chắc là tí thôi Phải
kiểm tra xem còn gọi ông nào export ở
tận hai fightwear không
Nói chung là tôi sẽ có hai cái loại trừ
một cái à trong cái thư mục đầy trong có
ai quen à cả giống như có ông kia kìa
đợi ông ấy bảo là quên chưa xuất file
hội là bây giờ nên chẳng có file quen là
cả thì tôi sẽ hiển thị thông báo lỗi là
cái nhóm này không có đúng ạ Và cũng
hiển thị thông báo lên các nhóm nào mà
có dẫn Hifi ngoại Ừ để mình tự làm thủ
công cái cái nhóm đấy cũng được ít nhất
là như thế bởi vì mấy cái trường hợp
ngoại lệ đấy ra nói Hữu rồi đúng ạ Đấy
xong rồi còn thêm cái gì nữa nhỉ À
à à môi còn thêm một cái tôi này nữa mà
tôi thì ra nói ngang qua cho đó là tôi
inbox tất cả đối mới về nhất là bằng ghi
top Laptop này thì ra Các bạn thấy nó sẽ
rất tiện ở điểm này của thử lên chính đi
hát của tôi tôi cho các bạn hình dung
nhé Tôi thử vào cái này
ấn vào đây khi mà tôi ẩn cốt rồi ấn Open
with này khi mà tạo ngay thì nó đã gần
như nó sẽ kiểu Clone hộ được sử đặt như
thế này
ở đây nó con thông báo à cái thư mục này
đã có rồi này phải ra xử cái này sẽ
chẳng thấy có này vẫn còn non thì sẽ kéo
được cốt về à chlor về không ạ Nhưng mà
mấy ông sẽ bảo là Thế thỉnh thoảng mà
Mấy bạn kia ở trong các nhóm khác cập
nhật cốt thì anh sẽ làm nhà tôi tôi thì
tôi nói tôi không không biết một câu
lệnh get là lâu nhá thì sẽ làm nhà tôi
có cũng có một cái tiện ích nữa ở trên
ppc tôm béo để chỉ là ông ạ Đây nó hiển
thị thông báo là đã có những cái những
cái nào Đang cần phải update cần phải
kéo Cốt về mới đây này tôi cài tiện đến
ngày rồi Nó là tiện ích nha Ghi chỉ nghĩ
kiếm chữ L hai cái ít thì gọi cho ông
xem nhé
I get toolbox này xong rồi cái tiện của
tôi ẩn control-t đấy đấy update tôi sẽ
kéo toàn bộ cốt mới của tất cả các thằng
ngày về lại rất tiện đứng nhiên lần đầu
của ông thì ông nghĩ ông sẽ phải đăng
nhập nữa nó hiển thị khung đăng nhập
không chuẩn đăng nhập thôi đấy tôi sẽ
kéo hết cốt nữa chị nó sẽ nó đó bây giờ
sẽ có cút mới
Mẹ nó bây giờ thì nói chung và bây giờ
mình sẽ bắt đầu cốt nhé
từ nãy giờ hơi rahman của bà Đông ạ Đây
mình sẽ bắt đầu cốt
từ ngày tôi hôm trước tôi tạo ở tủ chạy
thử đoạn này rồi cái đoạn này Thực ra là
tôi đi có cốt cả hai cái tôi cùng có cốt
thì cái thứ nhất cái từ khóa để lấy cái
này nó sẽ là gì nó sẽ là
ghét
file in
a directories p
directly dừng à thư mục chị ạ Đấy nó sẽ
có khái niệm dùng để Hàn này có thứ
nhưng mà Thôi lười quá đi có phản Cốt về
đây tôi thử cho mấy ông xem qua
Ừ cái cốt tôi đã cô về nhá á
Ừ tôi mà tôi lười Sáng nay ông ạ
từ khi cô school
bên đấy
ở đó nó đã ra được tất cả các
bí
thư mục đây mới chửi thư mục một cấp
thôi người ta Tôi muốn lấy à sâu hơn cơ
mà lấy xấu hơn thật cả Thế thì có này
vẫn chưa đủ
khi có kháng nghiệm mà này các bạn phải
biết về khái niệm mà cái từ khóa này từ
khóa này để quy cách làm chị ở lấy lấy
cái thằng con con con con nữa cho kiểu
lấy hết thì thôi đấy
cách tạo hầm Hào Môn xịt vãi
à à
À thế à
ờ ờ
từ ngày phát ra cái gì nữa
khi sex
abp-748 ngựa chạy được hình như nó chạy
đi Ừ thế thôi trói ông thử
bí thư chẳng mất gì cả đúng nó cứ thử
thôi
à à
a
Winner Tại sao ở đây mà không thấy tôi
dùng pin rồi vì là
đoạn này nếu mà em nếu để ý kĩ Kỳ
à à
chờ đợi tí tôi apply format lại đúng hay
ạ
ờ ờ
nhà hàng VIP phomat của tôi
à à
hai kỳ 3 Đinh Thanh Xuân huyện really
didn't
có hành vi format tụi bay rồi Thôi em
sạc thủ công vậy ạ
ừ ừ
Em không tin phật pháp này sẽ có phát
phát ở đây Trứng gà
Ừ từ một hiện tại thôi
Khi
nào có vẻ Thằng này nó sẽ gọi đến Á
destop à
Vì mình thấy có Windows này
bài hát của mình là cả cụ mày đi à
à à ừ ừ
em quá nặng phải đấy vì thằng này lấy
đúng rồi mà không thấy lấy cả con của
thằng kia đã đây là cái này sẽ rất nặng
Ừ ok
ở đoạn này
À
hôm nay ở nay cốt thì nó là tôi sẽ đi
bất thường tôi sẽ gửi đi Bắc lần lượt
nghe mấy ông sẽ thấy á đoạn nào khó hiểu
thì người sau từ từ hiểu sau nhé ạ
ở đầu tiên hài Lấy May vết
anh phải gì đấy ép wifi
à à
từ thủ đoạn cố này nó hơi khó hiểu
đợi rồi tính
em ở đâu Thời gian mình đâu cần là phức
tạp thế đó nhỉ Anh chỉ quan tâm việc cả
lấy file đuôi là SQL mày nghỉ
thế này này có đoạn đấy Làm này xịn với
ạ
ở đoạn này tớ nghĩa ổn hơn à
à à
a pop rồi nói
chuyện này mình sẽ lấy
nhớ rồi cái không mấy không ngờ đúng
không ạ Cũng chưa Còn làm bài kiểm tra
xong
mình sẽ chỉ quan tâm nên este đúng ạ Cái
đoạn này là
cho tất cả mọi cái
A và đây sẽ có nghĩa là đằng sau nó là
chấm skul Ok
anh được
Ừ nhưng mà thế này thì ra là bị nhược
điểm
Ừ nếu có thấy ở đây thôi à Ừ ok lấy được
file đấy nhưng mà
ờ ờ
Ừ cái này tôi tôi lại phải cắt chuỗi
chắc thế để mà kiểu biết được là cái
nhóm đấy không nhóm nào đang ở
em đang có wifi hay là nhóm là đang có 1
file
Em bán cả nhóm mà không có file nữa được
ngoại
À ra thế này không biết được nhóm lạ
anh à nếu thiếu tôi kết hợp cả hai cốc
đi Các bạn nhớ cốt vừa nãy không Cái cốt
này để lấy mỗi cái thư mục đầu ấy
Ơ con này về mỗi thư mục đầu này mà cho
mấy ông xem lại
đây nhá á
ở đây con này lấy thư mục đầu đông ạ
Ừ thì tôi sẽ
Á và một cốt nữa như vừa rồi Các bạn
thấy thì nó là lấy tất cả sai trong các
thư mục đấy
tự động hóa
Ừ Ok nếu thế mình sẽ kết hợp cả hai cái
này đầu tiên mình sẽ lấy cái toàn bộ tất
cả thư mục trước đó ông ạ nó sau đó thì
mình sẽ kiểm tra với từng thư mục đấy để
lấy từng cốt ra mình nghĩa cái đời rất
là ổn ok
có
chuyện bỏ phải đi võ đài đi này à
Ừ
được tiền thì mình à
chỉ cần bỏ cái thằng chấm ai đi tất cả
thì mình sẽ tại một cái mạng đấy đi
Android 7 Plus nghĩa là loại bỏ sẽ mình
cần bò một hành lá chè mai đi vào một
hòn chấm Temple thì không còn quan tâm
hay làm ngày à
Ừ nếu mà thằng này em ạ vì MJ
ô ma kiểu không nằm trong cái mạng trên
Ừ thì mình sẽ
chị sẽ cho nó ra đấy các bạn và bay thử
đầy các bạn xem qua đã sẽ nó đúng không
ở đó thấy không hề có ra nữa đúng ạ Ok
thì bây giờ mình sẽ là
ở đây thì ạ có từng thư mục rồi mình sẽ
nối chuỗi mình đây sẽ có chỗ ở đây rồi
phát ở đây là đừng dẫn thì mình kết hợp
với cái chỗ đấy à
rất
nhiều Paddy
sẽ bằng thép
với em rồi tất cả
I enjoy thích đổi tên ở đây được bản
chất Đây là thư mục đây mình thay đổi
Ngang Qua đây
Ừ nó
a directories
Ừ
nó thư mục
xanh đã rồi directories
sau đó thì toàn bộ code này
thì nó sẽ là
Ừ nó đi lấy ra cái để lấy ra được cái
file
It is well
ừ ừ
ở đầu tiên thì bây giờ tôi thứ Grow
cái hàng rách ra để các bạn xem có bài
viết cố tỏ ra hơi khó chịu nhớ méo mì ý
nghĩ Tự nhiên chữ cái đầu viết hoa trồng
rất là khó chịu
Ê thằng đâu là chống người sai thì sẽ em
nhé khi
add new part mày đúng khỏi phát nữa
à à
à à à đây phải nối nối chuỗi bằng mà gấu
giấu này à
ở đó mà không được đấy Như phát ra như
phát ở đây sao ạ ạ
xu hướng dẫn làm như thế hay trong này
không có
em không có phải em bé nhà mình nhớ
thương mục 1 có rồi mà đây này
ở đây tất cả giá này
à à
xe hơi sai sai à
3 bài 56 ạ
anh phải đi kiểu gì cậu sẽ ra thôi Mày
không đi Tao đi
làm qua ở ra không lâu lâu nó xem nào
Yên tĩnh nhé mình tĩnh nha à
anh không phối cả không Cái này được à À
nói óc chết nhỉ Ừ có thể thế
để tôi xem lại nha xin code nay nó sẽ
iPhone X và Alpha
karaoke Nó lấy va cho cho nó lấy gạch
Ừ thế thôi Cái Tôi đang muốn nó là chỉ
lấy 11 tháng đầu tiên thôi ra mình sẽ
đến thì sẽ đến ở đây này ạ
cho tôi thử
có tiền thì mấy ông bảo dùng phối đây
đúng không Cứ thử đã nhé với lại sẽ được
nhé á
Ừ nó ra Ok Thế làm chị ở dưới thằng phối
này nó sẽ lấy dữ liệu ra còn in a vừa
rồi nó check không thấy ra gì cả Ok
à à
Ừ nhưng mà như thế đến là gì nhỉ
Tôi thử Cao thằng ạ bye cao thằng này đi
xem có đến được nhé
không đến được nó abstract phối này nó
là
3000 Bạn bị nhầm rồi Cái thằng ghét cái
bản chất là nó đã lọc từ cái thằng này
ra rồi cái bản chất là nó lọc qua hết
tất cả hai ngày rồi còn đuôi cách này
đang trả về dữ liệu thôi rất này đang
trả về dữ liệu tất cả những thằng hợp
lại thôi chứ không phải là Thì ý bạn là
kiểu duyệt qua tất cả hàng đúng không
không không không ạ đâu
Thằng này nó là thằng Quý khách này bản
chất là nó đã trả về dữ liệu chuẩn rồi
theo như mình nghĩa là thế thì nghĩ thế
thôi mình không biết được nha rồi ông ấy
còn đuôi rách đến Lee gak nữa cháu rất
buồn cười
tôi để đây ếch nha Đang thử mấy ông xã à
ở đây à à
thế này Windows ra
à à
ừ ừ
A và
Ừ thôi như thế Tao phải tạm biệt đến thủ
công đi
à À ý bạn kia là ép nó Office thành
Android á Cũng được nhỉ bởi vì ở đây rồi
là nó check là thằng phối này hình như
nào ép nó thành ara không phải có ích
thì nó chạy được cảm giác được à
ở bài thử bài cao
vì bạn Nếu thế thì ngay đoạn này mình sẽ
ép nói hạ nghe được anh ở đây này
thì đây sẽ là tôi gạch
chị xe mày
anh không không trả lời gì cả
hơi sai sai
thôi không sao không sao Mình chơi cứ
chơi chuyển nông dân đi thì cho mình cao
ở đây bằng không chứ gì không ạ Nếu mà ở
đây có cái gì đó thì
khi mình tăng nó lên thôi ạ
ờ ờ
anh cao + +
Nghe được gì không ạ
à Xong rồi if
ờ ờ
chờ đợi đi
EX3 đây là gì
ở Pháp ép cao nhé
ở
Cao Bằng bằng một mình sẽ Thế chỗ pháp
về quê em ạ
à à
Ừ tôi sẽ đẩy cái này ra ngoài Tại sao
bởi vì à
à à
em heo ở đây anh sẽ Em chơi ở đây là
v-elf
Cao Bằng Bằng không Dạ không
tìm thấy file
con heo đánh nữa là
khi
có quá nhiều file em ạ
à à
cho thoải mái kéo y hỏi mày quen không
máy cao thì nó sẽ bị lỗi Bây giờ thì pp
đều dùng mai coi rồi
em
có về không thấy nói đi là được rồi đúng
không ạ Còn nếu ra sự không có file này
lịch sử tốt cho nó bay em ạ Sắp bày ra
ngoài ạ
ngay đi
thế hả bay ra ngoài khơi sai
Ăn tối tại một thư mục dẫm trước đi cái
để nó không đi chắc nó sẽ trồi lên trên
đấy nó cho anh trên ngoạn là thử đi nó
ra này không tìm thấy file nó thấy ở
phía hơn ở ngoại ô
Ừ anh sẽ cho iPad
anh alo alo tôi dictionary dictionary
này
direct directories đó
đó thì mình
eq200 nhất trả ạ
anh không định lấy file không ạ còn lấy
ra sử Xóa cái thua một máy đi
ý là như này
vì nó có file ok
Em thử phát nhỉ Xóa hết đoạn này đi là
ai
ăn chặn
33 giây rất nhanh
không xuống dòng như thế là chồng hơi
khó chịu thì tôi thử cái này là khi làm
xong một cái đi Chelsea rồi này thì mình
sẽ alo bây giờ sống lòng nhá á
ở đó
xe đẩy ra hết ngay không tìm thấy file
có file là hết
ở nhóm nào tự xem xét lại nha nhóm nào
không có file thì mấy ông mà để đuôi
file không phải ép word thì cũng không
chạy được tôi nhá của nhóm này có quá
như vai luôn này nhóm 14 quá nhiều file
Ok thử xem nhé Mỗi nhóm 14 này
ở quán nhiều fan không hiểu nghĩ vỗ bờ
ai tầm ashworth
em có khi tôi phải in nó ra à
à à
anh đi nó ra xem quá nhiều file à cụ thể
những file nào được
A A lô Đây Rồi đưa kết luận thì hợp lý
hơn
anh ra có có cách này nó hay phết này
tôi hồi trước tôi áp dụng cách này thì
chị mẹo thêm cho mấy ông nữa nhé mẹo hay
cực
khi mở thưởng ngày làm ở trường công ty
ở trong không xem từ trong nhà đi Chỗ
Nếu mà 1A Nếu mà bằng không
cài đặt thích
bằng không thì không tìm thấy
gà con
ở eo bit
cao lớn hơn 1 thì có quá nhiều file ở
chờ đợi gì 7k lên trên này tiền in ra
thư mục này chấm phẩy này đi nha từng
cái này
chỉ cách nhau bởi ở
ở đâu phẩy đi
chỉ cách nhau bởi dấu chấm phẩy cũng
được
Để tôi xem à
ừ ừ
[âm nhạc]
ăn cá nhiều file
Chị
Thơ bỏ in laser thì chỉ cần ngay độ in
ra nó sẽ phân biệt được sẽ cho ở đây
chấm phẩy I
A BAD or enter
À
mà tôi sẽ dùng xếp lưu
Ê mày không biết tại sao tôi dùng cái gì
gọi là chấm phải không ạ lại chỗ làm trò
này
anh
Kaisoul ship V và sữa ra ngay mà ông
chọn clip này chọn
Xiaomi có luôn đấy
thế này
Có ai như bị thừa mấy thằng đầu không
hiểu sao
nghe có ông sẽ thấy nó tách ra cái cây
chấm phẩy nó sẽ kiểu khi mà hết ra bên
Excel xong rồi tách nó phải tách từng
từng cái giá trị ra bởi dấu chấm phẩy
sợi ra được ngay
anh nói mày nhóm 25 này làm gì mà nó
file word này Alo
thế nhưng nhóm mày không chậm
à chị
Ý Nhi này nếu không Nhìn như hai rồi bảo
bảo tôi tôi cũng chịu chịu nha chị ạ
A gồm mấy mẹo hay cực lại cho chị mấy
ông số điển hình nhà tại nơi đây ẩn à
em ship control xong ở mũi tên Sang bên
phải
Ừ thôi Anh Delete đó tôi Tôi ghét kiểu
Nhìn cái kia trong nhiều quá
ừ ừ
Ừ anh ăn tối vợ giữ phím shift để mắc ăn
cho tất cả Cuộn này bằng nhau ấy tôi sẽ
ở nhà
các clip để cắt đuôi ấy
khi nãy mấy ông này số tận bún cái ạ Tôi
chịu đấy chị chị
à à
ạ Và bây giờ mới ông ấy bảo ở xóa hộ có
thường nữa bây giờ mấy ông cập nhật viết
luôn đi để tôi ấn ở đây thì anh cần sơn
t thôi cập nhật này mày không cần nhật
tự ghi để tải về được chưa ạ tôi chấm
từng nhóm để mở chữa bài mới không bao
giờ chết đấy thấy ông thì livestream mày
có cái lợi đấy mày ông sẽ bị lòi ra
những cái kiểu tật xấu của mấy ông và
mấy ông sẽ bị xấu hổ em ạ
có bốn cái đề về nhà ở
à à
Ừ ok Nói chung là bây giờ ra được đường
dẫn của từng file rồi Bên mình chỉ cần
đọc đọc cái file Nếu nhiều thì thôi ông
ạ Tôi sẽ có cái Hà mà đọc cái file rồi
tôi sẽ đây đặt wi-fi từ cái luôn dẫn sau
đó thì có cái Hàn này tôi cũng copy từ
hôm trước thôi
để copy code từ hôm trước vợ chồng nhớ
tôi gõ từ khóa là gì
In post
em inbox
Apple find
anh có thể dùng bạn bye TP được nhận
thức ra chữ P là đủ rồi
em gái yêu Dinh pp là hãy thử đấy nó ra
đoạn cũ này có về thì ra đoạn này à nhớ
là không chạy Mình nhớ bạn lại không gặp
phải cái thẳng mình copy của thằng dứa
lắm chạy không sao Mình cũng copy mà
mình quan trọng gì đâu chú đại khái nói
như thế này đúng ạ Cái đoạn này nó xóa
luôn cả toàn bộ những cái chú thích này
chỉ lấy những cái đoạn quan trọng anh
Paul thành công Đấy à
à à
anh kia tôi cần bây giờ là gì thì như
tôi đã nói tôi muốn tự động hết tất cả
ra ngoài để một lần sau tôi chỉ còn chạy
cái này thì nó hiển thị ra ở đây là
thằng này có file này thằng này đã chạy
nhanh công đối ngoại Ok
mà chỉ chạy với nhóm nào có 1 file thôi
đúng không ạ
ở những nhóm có nhiều file bỏ qua quả đó
ngoại cái bản chất ở đây là gì mình cần
lưu đóng này vào mạc và mình sẽ kiểu
mình Mình sẽ lưu lại thằng nào được phép
chạy 1 hoặc không không ạ nhưng mà đương
nhiên tí mình sẽ phải in cái mảnh thì ra
để hiển thị là thằng nào đấy inbox thành
công họ không được phải Inbox để kia thế
là sự tôi muốn in ra ở đây mày ông sẽ
hình dung tôi sẽ có thêm cột ở trên này
chẳng lại nó sẽ là số nhóm này
bên này sẽ là à
em inbox thành công ấy thất bại Đông ạ
đấy à
Vì sao nói gì đây là có thể ở bên này
thì pass của file ảnh án có bao nhiêu
file hiển thị ra hết giống như này này
ngoạn nhưng bên này tôi tôi chỉ quan tâm
Thực ra là thường là mình sẽ quan tâm
sâu nhóm nữa cả những có thành công hay
thất bại ở bên bên này thôi ông ạ Hôm
nay like cốt mày Ông Đông Ấy
nãy giờ mày ông hiểu cái Nếu có thể
không biết tốt cả tội tôi biết cô đâu
Nãy Cốc Cốc màn không ạ Nếu có chọn tôi
biết sửa gì tôi Tôi làm quen rồi đúng
không ạ nhưng mà nãy giờ mấy ông hiểu
được ý tưởng của tôi không ạ
Khi bữa nói đông quá tự nhiên giản luôn
10 ông ấy
nếu ông vào cuối giờ này mà xem cái gì
đó đúng không Hôm nay chẳng có gì chia
sẻ ngoài cái này đâu ạ
Ừ đấy thì à nha méo hiểu ý tưởng tôi
chưa Giờ không làm tiếp thôi mình cần
nói chung cần hiển thị ra đây post thành
công ấy thấy bạn đấy đại ca như thế
Ê tụi nó nãy giờ tôi tôi nói thế mà mày
cũng không hiểu nữa thì tội không thể
giải thích thêm này là được thời sự liên
hệ này thì à
ở đài mình sẽ trong một mảnh sẽ xong cả
rồi à
Ê
mày không có cập nhật đi Tôi làm xong
cốt này tôi chạy ông làm mà không được
mất quyền lợi thì thôi
Mình
mạnh này của mình thì sẽ đây nêm này
chẳng hạn
vẻ
đẹp Thái à
I III
anh bình tĩnh miễn phí
anh lại thấy mình cứ mỗi cái dictionnary
này
có mỗi cái dictionary Night
ở
cái chỗ này thấy sai của sao một cái
dysentery này không không nằm trong danh
sách này vợ thì mình sẽ tạo một cái Bim
đêm mình sẽ đây một biến là biến Index
đi
tại lại dùng vòng vo rồi bằng lập fuik
nghe mình phải tạo nên cái bị đến ở
ngoài
thì mình sẽ Inax + Cận
và Đây mình sẽ với cái biến Index đấy
thì sẽ có nên nêm giờ đây chính là số
nhóm đấy là số nhóm này từng cái tháp
này mình sẽ play tại vị trí từ Index tại
vị trí thử Pháp
số
kiểu truyền chuyển thêm vào trong mạng
thì sẽ dùng chồng like để chuyển tiền 3A
a&f
ờ ờ
apply tại Index II
Ừ
cái mạng em ạ nhiều chiều nhiều ôm không
không rõ cái này lắm nhưng mấy ông sẽ
hơi khó hiểu một tí tôi làm quen với
việc 30 chiều được quen không sao
đến cái nón này nếu mà đến nay bằng bằng
thì mình sẽ cho về Andrei tại Index
mình sẽ biến là import
bằng chu đi
em sẽ tăng phone cũng được hoặc là mấy
ông muốn làm cái tiện hơn thì mấy ông sẽ
có thể mặc định cái này bằng
a
cho quý ốc lai mặc định trước bằng chú
sau đó thì nếu mà đếm lạch thì mình sẽ
cho thành phone một cách
ở đâu Thật ra không cần phải đếm lại cái
này ông chỉ cần cao như này được rồi
phụ nữ không nghe được mà à
Ừ ok crowd in phone nói chung Tôi thử
in lại cái mà vừa rồi xem nó hợp lý
không đã
à à
anh Duyệt file gì nhỉ
áo phông cái chấm mày cãi về đồ án chế
chấm rồi mà
Khi dòng 19 sai tại sao xanh đấy
I say in Tech tại nêm bằng
cho android tại Iraq
Vì sao nhỉ
ở cục sex
em lại nói cho anh đây tại vị trí kỹ
Index bằng mạng đi mà chắc cú lúc đầu là
mạng chấm
35 14 đã sai rồi
à Anh nhầm đẹp cái này xin lỗi xin lỗi
sự không không không cần phải báo hiện
nay sẽ không đúng không
vì
nó không phải ra được dữ liệu này nhưng
phát thành công nên có thành công Ok Ok
Rồi mình sẽ làm thôi mình sẽ là vô ích à
I III I
ex2 Hãy inbox I
ở đây là nếu mà chuối không ạ Mình sẽ
cho laptop
mà copy toàn bộ Cái này và
à à
anh Khanh Lai
a Pot máy queo này
a database
cho nên chị sẽ băng đô lại x tại Mê mẹ ạ
bài hát ở đây sẽ là à
Cho
Ax tại Pháp
à à
vì nó có hot root
Ừ để tôi thử
Windows thằng đầu tiên các bạn đã luôn
test kỹ cẩn thận đã đay thằng lại xem có
in được trong đầu tiên của tôi là vậy
file này chị sẽ em có lấy được đúng cái
hoài không
a file name
ở Tháp
ở tại vị trí được không
Ô thế sao đầu tiên em ạ
vợ chồng về ra rồi đó
có con rồi thì đây mình cần thêm một câu
đó là mình sẽ giúp cái
thì mình sẽ phải lốc nó đi Ừ lúc nào tao
bay đi
Chờ Đợi mình tí nhé
thì mình sẽ cần load data bay đi đã rồi
mày mời Á tại lại
Ừ nó bị hơn
anh ở đây Vợ ở đây trong trường hợp này
tôi đã tạo cho ta bây cho cái hành một
rồi hôm trước làm thủ công đấy hôm hôm
hôm qua thử làm thủ công đồng một thôi
mình có ba nhỏ mỗi Tôi thấy mệt quá nên
tôi nghĩ phải làm tôi như thế này à
à à
à à Chưa được rồi bạn thấy Kìa Ok có
những nhóm có nhiều nhóm mày chưa được
duyệt thật thì thì tôi sẽ đem lại còn
những nhóm được rồi tôi cứ chậm đã nóng
ạ tí thôi phải so sánh đối chiếu với cái
file Excel cũ của tôi nữa đấy một mình
tôi làm hơi bị nhiều việc à
Ừ tôi chưa thử vụ là thử kết nối không
cần datapes sau đó thừa chrysanthemum sẽ
xem
em thử xem uống nhận đây để tôi thử phát
nhé tôi một tí sẽ có cốt này sao một cái
file đặt tên là file test 2.tp đi đầy
cây này
để mình sẽ có các thứ thứ này mình đổi
đây là tự nó không phải filename nữa đâu
có hot này mình không có Doctor đây này
là sự như này đi
Em xem mình có tạo được đặt ra đây khi
mà chị kết nối này không bằng
class
a ta bay 1
thứ hai
ngày sau đó thì mai quay EZ Connect
FA sẽ thư pháp
Ừ thôi chưa có cốt mấy cái này vào rồi
đâu nên tôi cứ chạy mãi tôi không chắc
chắn ước điều gì cả
em không có Tại sao
Ừ rồi thêm cái quét nữa
nó vừa rồi tôi
Anh có thấy đâu nhỉ À không không nói
hiển thị ra sau không ra được
cụ thử pin rồi à
nhà máy cơ Y Euro xem
à à
à à à à
a
christa b đường mà nhờ bầy iCloud
khi có lệnh nói như thế nào nhỉ
khi có lệnh Kris đã thấy bình thường mà
nghỉ tại sao nó báo lỗi cú pháp tại số 2
nhỉ
Ừ bắt buộc phải nằm trong thùng Ái
để
tạo ra bình thường mà copy vào chạy thử
xem được nha à
em
về cái này thì ra đã từng có bạn hỏi ai
Tôi tra lại các bạn lần Cuội tôi chưa
cha mày Ông cho tôi từng trả lời rồi đó
thực à Nếu mà file chỉ có pp thì các bạn
không nên đóng thẻ mà hãy để nó tự đóng
vậy không các bạn sẽ gặp cái lỗi là lỗ
trắng Anh Face P
ở đây
anh không Không phải cả mọi cái này ờ
Euro
[âm nhạc]
ừ ừ
ý
đồ tác à
nghe này FPT tại sao không không nên
không nên đóng thẻ wi-fi chị đã phải P
khi
đôi khi thỉnh thoảng sẽ thừa cái kiểu và
xuống dòng hè một cái cậu ở Thừa Cái Dầu
cách từ đằng sau như thế này thi thử ta
cái nếu mà bị thừa Thế có điều gì sẽ xảy
ra bởi vì đôi khi là nó sẽ bị cậu không
chuyển hướng được trang khi mà các bạn
để he Đồ bé một cái Điền hình các bạn
thừa cái dấu nhận dấu một dấu cách đằng
trước này đôi khi các bạn nhận ra Nhân
Vật thừa dầu cách đằng sau như thế này
các bạn sẽ có bơ nhận ra được à Không ạ
nó vô cách mà chị em tôi là các bạn
chẳng ý y thì khi mà các bạn dùng header
location đợi em một cái điển hình ngoài
tuổi Tôi không biết được các trường hợp
khác như là một khi các bạn dùng cái
điều hướng chuyển hướng Sang trang khác
thì các bạn không được phép petrol hay
là hiển thị đã bất cứ ghế gì ở trang web
các bạn thì các bạn mình điều hướng được
còn mù kia các bạn có thêm một cái dấu
cách thôi là nó không điều hướng được
hãy cho một ví dụ
hôm
nay tôi muốn có cách này ạ
do đó trường hợp mẹ được này thủ có nhớ
rồi chưa Không được nghỉ à
à à
Ừ ok lại đường kì ảo thế
Nhưng mình ở mình nhớ hồi sữa không được
xe Howo mình bị lỗi gì nữa cơ đại phá à
không phải tự nhiên tôi chém đó ra đây
nó khuyên Hẳn là không không không nên
có cái đóng
Thế mẹ gửi thừa này tôi tôi tôi nhớ thôi
chứ tôi bị cái vụ đấy thì cái vụ chỉ
những vụ header này tôi nhớ thêm trên
còn gì nữa cơ à
anh
em ở quyền trực quay về test 2 Bảo sao
p2.tp nhé à
anh không nó vẫn đều hưởng trẻ quá thôi
bỏ qua đi coi như là ở có thể hết đầu là
không bị lỗi nhưng mà
Ừ
nhưng mà chắc chắn là cái này nó nó nó
rủi ro này
lý do liên quan được khoảng trắng đằng
sau nó cái này tôi vẫn đúng đây đây nó
vẫn nói qua liên quan được thấy đời này
thấy không có
anh không chém đâu ạ
em Anime
tôi có những cái mà tôi không biết thì
tôi sẽ nói không biết có những cái mình
tôi chắc chắn rồi cháu sẽ không Tôi có
lẽ là trong trường hợp này có thể nó
không ra lập trình viên mà quen quen dần
việc là đô thị cỡ là mình biết sẽ tàn
điều gì đó như cốt mãi không chạy nó
ngoại đi
Ừ
đúng là lỗi này à
à À đúng rồi chắc à này là chuỗi cho ở
đây thiệu Ok Thế sao chạy được
Vì sao toàn tiếng Anh đó
ông nội tôi à Hồi tôi không biết rồi nó
mấy ông chưa Nhưng mà thôi trước anh
không phải anh đi có Dạ tôi đi có dạ mà
Ừ từ trong quyển sách của spider-man tôi
đọc hay phết Nó có một câu đó là mua khi
mà các bạn đợi đến khi nào mà nó dịch ra
thành thị tiếng Việt cho các bạn thì các
bạn đọc với
anh thiệt thì công nghệ lấy đô xin lỗi
thời rồi
Ừ cái này để hình Dung rõ hơn nhá đó là
thế ra số người mà thành công đã ít số
người mà còn chia sẻ nó lại còn ít hơn
mà số người mà chia sẻ lại còn dịch nó
ra tí nữa không ạ Mà mấy ông đợi đến cái
số người dịch ra để như thế đúng không ạ
Ừ thì đi sau qua bao nhiêu người ngựa đó
ngoại
ở Châu Phi ở người Việt mình tự Mỹ là
cái đầu tiên thôi thì may ra có tài liệu
tiếng Việt trước còn thường là cái này
toàn mà toàn là mình mình đang học lại
mà ngoãn địa đi sau người ta rồi ông ạ
Còn đợi mà nó dịch ra tiếng Việt mấy ông
thì đầu như kiểu bây giờ tôi đang dạy
mấy ông này có khó khi cái này đang lỗi
thời dần rồi đấy ạ Không ạ nên mấy ông
càng biết thêm ngôn ngữ không phải một
tiếng Anh mà càng biết thêm thì đã sản
là mấy ông sẽ càng có thêm kiểu có thể
tự chủ động trong việc học hơn đội người
khác đội khác kiểu chia sẻ lại đúng
không ạ là qua tay bao nhiêu người còn
không biết được người ta chia sẻ có đúng
hay sai nữa đúng không ạ rất nhiều cái
A Gọi Tam sao thất bại nữa ạ Không hẳn
là dịch Láo cái gì cả nhưng mà có thể
lấy cho nó họ không truyền tải được đúng
đầy đủ đúng ạ ấy thì sao thì mấy ông lại
thiệt Mình họp sau họ những đợi đợi
người ta học xong chán chê người ta mới
dịch kia ông em Nếu không học lúc đấy
lương của ông ấy cũng chắc chắn cũng
phải theo phân họ đúng không ạ ạ
Ừ ok Nói chung là bây giờ
quay trở lại đây Tí và rồi xa lỗi Bây
giờ chú ý thử tải lại bây giờ sẽ là tạo
được
Ừ bác cũng không tạo được
số BTV2 của tôi đâu mà
ô hay bị thiếu nhỉ
anh ở đây xe máy
Anh kéo đi
em bị lỗi Cả ngày hai cái nhỉ
a red-letter bay hay đi sai đấy heo à
em xem nhá Ừ
à à
ừ ừ
10 cái này ạ Nó là đối tượng mới rồi
Anh ơi y a red-letter bay
anh vẫn được mà Thấy xàm gì cả
vì nó muốn nó trẻ hay thôi
em chưa đây nữa ABC đấy là được trả được
các cạnh AB BC mà bây giờ mới rảnh đã
đỡ heo hãy bắt bộ đi kiểu nha
thử nhé à
à à
xe máy cao bình thường có không có phân
biệt hoa thường thì không nhỉ Hay vẫn
lỗi cạnh hai Cai nhỉ
à à
xin lỗi cạnh 2a
anh không nói nữa
à hài á
anh khó hiểu kiểu gì
để tạo đường ạ
anh đọc Thượng Thử lại không thể tin
được tạo bình thường mà
lỗi cạnh hai ok
xong cái đó chạy trên này vẫn được thôi
Nhớ do cái thằng Mai Quý Cao này thằng
Mạnh A cái thằng Hà mua máy queo này chứ
đôi khi là mấy ông chạy được trên mạng
trên pass admin nhưng vài máy nào cũng
được mà ngược lại
đây tôi tạo ở trên này mấy ông bảo như
này đúng không
khi nghe tôi vừa rồi thiên tôi nháy được
mà
anh em vẫn không được thật mà
Vì thế tôi tạo cái kiểu bằng tool thì
được cái này cái tôi hơi khó chịu ở điểm
chế tạo cái bằng tool thì nó lại không
ra cốt để mình có không biết được cấu
tạo bằng cách thần thánh à
Ê cho tao đây bằng số mà không ạ Trông
thấy tôi ta ở đây bằng số bình thường mà
cách tạo rất bình thường
thứ hai tôi thử export nó ra xe máy
Ừ đúng rồi tôi sẽ export nó ra sau đó
thì à export cả cái câu crash database
nó ra được
em không bắt đầu bằng số được cả ông lại
cho em tôi cái cái này cái gì đấy à
ừ ừ
đã có câu a red-letter bay đây
em xem cái này biết ngay mà
à à
ừ ừ
Em vẫn chưa ngủ giàu này ok rồi
em nghe không say được
Ừ ngày mới mới mới bình thường thì thôi
thương ai dùng dầu ngày Nói thật nha
ngày này ở trong mà ở
Ừ đúng rồi nháy tôi thương ấy dùng ở
trong tên bảo vệ tên cô tôi chơi thử với
tên ra sân bay Nội Tôi nói tôi
Ừ ok thế này có vẻ ổn đấy ạ
em hãy thử lại nhé
chế độ nói 20 đi ừ
anh không báo lỗi đã được thông báo lỗi
là chạy được rồi
Ừ hôm nào bảo chỉ số chỉ chữ đâu đúng
không ạ số được mà nó không ạ
Anh nhớ về rồi tôi Em muốn làm đó là tôi
Crop mà đã sau đó tô quét lại nó hiểu
thì thôi ông ạ Sau đó tôi sẽ yêu nó nó
hợp lý hơn
anh gọi tên em đi Khánh chân hả
Ý bạn là gì cơ
Em không biết được có chạy ưu để trong
này không
à à tiện thể test luôn Tôi sẽ thử yêu ở
đây Tôi đỡ mất công tạo cái phần con ếch
lại phát nữa
tôi sẽ
yêu
viết hoa trong mấy ông bảo là chỗ trắng
được nhé
à à
Em hãy phát nữa này sau đó thì ạ
ờ ờ
a
snack một cái gì đó thì cái snack bất kỳ
cái gì đó cũng được
anh sai mà có lỗi gì không
Anh không có lỗi tức là được rồi
tôi nghe ưu được đóng nhạc yêu được nghĩ
thế
khi họ thì bây giờ mình sẽ xóa đoạn này
đi mình sẽ crash ta bây giờ đây
ô tô dốt mà đi cơ sở sẽ dốt nó sau đó tô
class II
số
tiền nhỉ À
Lotte Pie
anh alo
baby kết của này lên nhé
à à Anh dốt mà đi Nghĩa xóa đi cho chắc
mà à
a
respectable ê
EX3 ten o'clock bỏ đi này
Anh đang sẽ là
mình đặt tên data bane Ê mày đây
ở
bảng ích Tại lên mày ạ à à
anh sữa đỏ gì đây sẽ là tôi bay lên đấy
ạ sau đó thì Tạ lại ở đây này
ạ
sau đó thì yêu nó
ở Nam Á
à à
ạ
sau đó đi ỉa Mình sẽ khi người yêu xong
rồi thì chạy tất cả câu dưới nhìn thường
thôi
Ừ hi vọng là mấy ông ở trên này Mickey
code của mấy ông này trong này không có
press không có
quyết tâm bây
ở những việc ở chắc chắn mình sẽ
anh gọi
ở cái đoạn này in lỗi à
à à
Em không biết được đoạn này in lỗi in bị
lỗi
à à
gì hả mày hình như nó không trả về cho
phone nữa thì mày im nó lỗi còn này
thì mình sẽ đây
à à
Mẹ kiếp
I MT connect
ông
Michael piro Connect
mà có có lỗi thì mình sẽ free Nó ra
I
II nổ ra từ cái này intro đấy ạ
u&i nó ra này
em gọi cho nó từ từ thôi
anh chạy tự trong đầu tiên đã nào Nếu
không chữa cháy hàng nào bay thử xem nào
ạ
xe
chạy thôi Bum
dự báo lỗi rồi còn cho
à 24 giờ 15 đã lỗi không hiểu
khi trồng 15 lỗi
a new car
Ừ
hình như à Tôi vừa
đẩy được mà sẽ thấy báo lỗi nhỉ
à À đúng rồi tôi bị thừa cái Fighters 2
và xóa file types đổi tội lỗi
à à
I Connect gồm 47 size
ở vòng 4 7
U2 tô hệ tặng con ếch ở đây tôi tạo con
ếch ở trên này mới đúng
á nhon
Ừ Ok có vẻ
anh
nhìn lỗi Xem dòng khác là vui rồi
ở không mà lỗi gì cả có thể thành công
Đấy thử xem lại nhé
chú chó
một điều chắc để cho mấy ông Nghĩa là
tôi không bịp tôi sẽ Hôm trước mày không
bảo chút ít nhắn thôi buồn lắm Nó sẽ dốc
hết mấy cái hang này đi được ngoại không
ngờ ngoài kia chút ít
à
Không có gì đúng không ạ Ok chạy sự này
Anh đang chạy thử một hàng thôi không ạ
ra mắt 4 giây Thực ra bây giờ mắt 10
giây hay mười mấy giờ thấy sản nhanh hơn
bằng tay tí mình chặn một phát lại file
mày không ạ
Anh ta lại đó đâu Tao B1
gì đó Alo chị nào nó thấy xứng đáng nãy
rồi cốc hơn 1 tiếng không đáng có khi
thụ có nghĩa là khi xong rồi nhau nhưng
mà mình hãy nghĩ bài toán lâu dài nữa đó
là mình sẽ dùng em thường xuyên tôi lần
nào mà mình đã
ở
cực cùng mỗi lần nào mình kiểu cần cập
nhật các hiệu thứ mình chạy file này
thôi đúng ạ đấy mấy ông đừng có
khi export một cái file tài ba lỗi xong
rồi để tôi import vào không được rồi tôi
lại đi trách các thứ thứ nhé Lúc về tôi
bỏ qua nhóm của ông ấy đi
Ừ
ok Nói chung là nhóm đầu thì có vẻ ổn
thôi mấy nhóm sau toàn ngay mà
em hãy thử nhỉ à
em được ăn cả ngã vì không à đâu Mấy ông
vừa nãy bảo anh đấy gì Ok cho anh biết
nha lấy đó Tắt bếp lần cô ấy nghỉ thôi
tôi chấm chuyện với ông không thể chạy
theo bé uống suốt được không ạ Buồn lắm
à à
ờ ờ
bài hát mấy ông Định Cài mã độc vào ấy
thắng học lập trình Ai thắng học hay
khủng đấy
Ừ thế giờ rồi thế tôi mở xoa bóp được
mấy ông thích thế tôi mở sáng bóc cho
con sẵn bóc mà Windows săn báu vật mở
lên chơi mày không giống hack thì cũng
lắm mà khách của ta bây của ôm khác thôi
mình galetin bay của tôi
bên trên mày cá nhân của đội nào có cái
gì cả người không thích thì mấy ông cái
phê Black có đã có về công ty ra đây
công ty của tôi là tôi chỉ lưu giữ dữ
liệu gấu xác ở trên máy thôi nghĩa cùng
bằng ông xem được cấu trúc của của thư
mục
Ở nhà thế cũng hết rồi
thử xem Bây Ông thấy thế nào không đi
chơi chắc cú hơn là tôi cứ tắt mạng đi
cho tôi chạy được file này thì mấy ông
không thể nào mà tắt mạng đi làm gì ở
chuyện mình gửi file đều trông đúng
không ạ
từ trước khi mở chạy trước khi nhầm cái
gì đó Cái tôi không biết
Ừ
ok tại thả như này à
Ừ vậy thôi mình tự nhiên thấy chút nhé
ở tiền đây là
em nhớ mang tên mình vẫn đi chỗ đã cho
Đô lại ít tại nêm này
thế cho dòng này À cái ca này
cái chỗ đấy
I
bought này
là không ở đây ở trong trường hợp mà
Em hãy hiểm mà có sai mình sẽ có bình
trách
mình trách
alo yêu cầu bằng phone sẽ không có lỗi
nếu mà có lỗi thì mình sẽ
cho biển trách
Euro bằng chu
họ lỗi Và đây là để cho
ích tại
á Thế George e calo hơn được
khi xu phone gì đó Ok cho EXO
nhân ai ở Chiều tiếp và thích là không
Mẹ nó là
à à
bộ phim lost
xe khách tại khác Tại sao lại dùng
Androi vì bản chất lập tháp này nó làm
mà mình sẽ in toàn bộ cái mạng này cách
nhau bởi dấu chấm phẩy
sau đó thì đây cho xuống dòng
tôi chạy Thực ra tôi cũng chưa dám chạy
tất cả các file đâu mà tôi sẽ chạy thử 2
file trước đi mình sẽ tạo một cái ở đây
là một cái biến Index
và đây mình sẽ có là à à
à à
ex2 ntech bằng bằng 2
hay 3 pha đây để mà không đến tôi không
mà mình sẽ cách lại à
ở Hải Dương à
khi tôi đến thời gian á Tết Lo tang
à à
Khi phát sinh closed After a grade
ha ha ha
em hết bị ngược mình xin lỗi sẽ bị ngứa
à
à à
ở trại nào
có hai nhóm nhóm 1 và nhóm 11
Ừ cái Chu này có vẻ là nó không in ra
được
vì vậy chuông iPhone thì nó không vậy ký
tự gì gì đó
em tôi đặt tên nó lại xy ngay cái này là
ý thức ăn Mình chỉ quan tâm cái nào mà
Báo lỗi nhỉ không có lỗi còn này sẽ là
có lỗi cho nhìn này nó cũng được
anh
không Alo gì Ra đây sẽ không có lỗi gì
đâu đó tôi thử tải lại bên này thì ra
nãy giờ rốt mấy phát cái thẳng đã B1
chẳng qua nãy giờ ra sân bay của mấy ông
vẫn nhẹ nên tôi mình sẵn này chơi máu
liều inbox như thế nào ạ bây bạn này bên
này bạn thôi mà cũng ít thôi Thứ điệu
mấy ông đang chưa có gì cả bơ mấy ông
thử ta bây giờ mấy mê ạ bắt tôi chạy cái
này chết treo máy
Nghe có vẻ ngon đấy chứ không ạ Alo gái
yêu rồi alo alo alo
Anh ở nhiều nãy giờ mà khổ hai trái rồi
sẽ sai nữa đấy mình ai nên mình nghĩ đến
mình được không mà nhá ở đâu từ một à sẽ
nói nách mình từ một thành ra là cả đúng
hay sai thật mình sửa lại nha mình cho
nó là năm đi
áo khoác Beo thử hạn chế lớn đi một số
thứ 5 đùa đùa đấy năm chưa đã
cho mấy một mấy một tiếng rưỡi rồi Không
lâu lắm nhé tôi tôi gọi lên lấy hai
tiếng rồi đó lỗi rồi này nó cứ bị tôi
xin lỗi này lỗi này là bởi này không tin
thấy file Đúng rồi này không có file
phát ra hỏi chấm OK thì lại mình sẽ phải
cho pass nó cũng giống trước đã sau đó
thì truyền vào thì nó sẽ đúng
cho
anh Hải là được
Ừ nó
à à
ở vòng 42 lỗi
số 42 phát tại không kế Tháng 12 này
Tháng 12 này Tại sao nói như thế này
trong bể hai lại alo import nó vào được
a.how cho bằng chu
Anh bảo rồi Nếu nó bằng 0 thì nữa là
được Dạo này hơi sai đấy Dạo này phải À
như này đi
từ lúc đầu bằng phone xong rồi bữa nay ở
Chu thế đó sẽ luôn luôn rồi à
anh
làm sao mình biết sửa nhanh mà
cô gái gái gái Alo Alo Alo nó cái đưa
đúng không ạ Alo alo alo
hình ảnh những thế check Hero ở đây nó
lại không được à
Đợt Đợi tí nhé
Ừ cái này lúc đầu nữa lỗi mà nó không ạ
Nếu mà không có file thì thằng này nó
vẫn thể lỗi
Có ai như này
em
có phai thì nó sẽ là dẫn sau đó thì lại
lỗi
Ừ ừ như thế cho ở đây là không đi không
có file này Đây là rỗng tất cả không có
lỗi này ở đây sẽ là lỗi này hợp lý
Alo Vẫn gái chứ vẫn này cái gì
em
chưa 100 lòng nhé mời ông về đâu tôi còn
tôi xuống do ngồi nhiều đấy 1978 rồi
ở đó không có file bị không copy cái này
sang bên này là gái rồi bố ạ
anh xóa đoạn này đi
Xóa hết đi
a control ship
v-bit chọn như này đó
em gái inbox không người sẽ hiểu là
không có file không ạ
cho hợp lý
Ừ thôi khó chịu nhất là thằng này tôi
chọn cái này rất là lúc được lúc đầu mà
em thấy rồi chọn Cái này nó là cắt cái
này rồi cũng có lần pass nó ra nó lại
ghi để lại Phả Lại phải cắt lại cãi vãi
ngoài là về cơ bản này vẫn ngon thì khó
chịu mỗi người thôi
Ở đây có vẻ ổn không Xóa đi
một lần chưa lớn xem mọi người có châm
cho em
ừ ừ
Khi
bữa rồi à 58 phút lỗi
a-class table is not axit đúng rồi Cái
lỗi này là do bên ông ông nhóm 19 Hôm
qua gửi cho tôi cái file
file Linh Đan tinh mà say à
kế hoạch cái sai lầm lỗi luôn cả chỗ
khác à Tùy cái quá vào nhóm 19 xóa sư
file đấy à
Ai file này không phải file Excel chuẩn
này phải linh tinh
à à
cách để sửa bất hạnh xa sử rẽ nào nó gây
lỗi để thế là được thật là mấy ông vừa
rồi thấy rồi ra tôi đến cái đoạn này vẫn
được rồi ông ạ Tôi có thể là skip nó
nhưng mà thôi nhưng cứ chạy lại
à mình mình mình cứ chạy lại để mình in
nó ra mà hết nó ra à
Ừ tôi vẫn gái Đấy thế là nổi thì là sinh
viên của tôi Ông mấy ông hôm trước cũng
hỏi tôi là tôi nghiêm túc với sinh viên
tôi không Thực ra cũng có nghiêm túc nó
về cơ bản tôi gái hơn nhiều thì nhá sinh
viên cũng học cái rồi lỗi à
Ừ cái gì tôi nói ông ấy thì hôm qua rồi
ông ấy bảo bị sai Các bạn đấy
Vì sao đây mà con bị lỗi em ạ
ở bảng này đã tồn tại mình dốt nó rồi
Mày nghỉ
đợi xem
thằng 16
anh
đọc kịch link file database
à
à B giúp đốt nó lại quét lại
a-class lại rồi con bằng tên khác ạ Xóa
đi sau
đó bây giờ sẽ không đổi nữa hợp lý
Ê mấy ông kia cho vẫn rồi ok
300 nhóm 20 nhóm 19 Hôm qua làm hết rồi
rằng tôi nhá Tôi ghim làm tôi chưa khi
chấm nhóm khác
Ừ thế là nhóm 19 Hôm qua làm tôi nghĩ là
tôi phải làm của mẹ cái tu này à
ừ ừ
ở nhóm 22 Quốc bị này
Ok Glass đã tạo
vợ thế nhỉ
à à
Ừ mình tĩnh mình không thể chơi mình
không thể cứ cứ mỗi lần bị như này xong
rồi Thậm chí các bạn hãy còn cập nhật
lên nữa đúng không ạ vẫn có thể chơi này
được mình phải chơi là mình sẽ phải
thì mình phải à Bỏ đi cái câu class là
tầm bậy
Ừ nếu hiểu gì không ạ hãy dùng cái này
sắp chiếu sinh này kiếp này mình sẽ bỏ
câu christa b đi
mình sẽ thêm đây ghi kiểu đi vào code
người ta còn mình cho mẹ chồng chuyên
nghiệp newsky đi sẽ không lỗi là Slip
dress ta bây I
Ừ nó
Em sắp chữ trinh ở kiểm tra rồi em có
không ấy thì đây là thực ra là mình sẽ
mà mình có thể ạ trên Ford xin tôi thử
lại ngay kiểm tra trong chuỗi đấy nó sẽ
có câu Kris là đâu bài không
bỏ qua lại
là
đỏ như thế này mũ Hoàn qua cái đấy
em bỏ qua cả yêu nữa à
à à
ừ ừ
ông ngoại tình cảm sẽ bỏ qua mày trả lại
đó
thì sẽ không lỗi hợp lý không
anh bình tĩnh phết
em tự thưởng
U22 đời tôi xe máy nhé đó cũng Minh
à à
phụ
kiện bao tập 7 có yêu đó 132 dòng này có
thể lỗi được
trái phải nữa
anh
vẫn nhanh nhỉ Hai mấy giây thấy ông bây
giờ lần sau tôi chỉ chạy mỗi tôi này
inbox hết Giống như cái tôn này của tôi
để mà lo hết toàn bộ code mới của mấy
ông về này đấy ông ạ xong tôi việc vào
sau đó thì tôi sẽ vào kiểu sẽ vào đường
link ở nhà school that một đó bấm vào
bên admin thì sẽ thấy toàn bộ bền admin
Có cái gì nó sau đó thì đây đổi ai trông
như này
Tại ăn Min khách hàng như thế này đó là
thật hay đùa đấy kiệm như thế đúng ngày
thôi mất lỗi What the f***
cậu xanh có gì đây vẫn còn hai cái file
mà không có ra cristales
à À đúng rồi
Ừ cái này tôi chưa thêm phải là
bằng bằng phone thì bằng Chút mình sẽ bỏ
qua
Em ở chỗ nào khác phone
mình sẽ bỏ qua Quyền Quỳnh
10 cái đoạn này vẫn đúng rồi chị sửa một
tí thì tôi thích Thôi
em cứ bình tĩnh xem à
anh
không gái không bao giờ là sớm mà phải
phải cái sớm này nó cái sau còn cái được
nói về sau thắng rồi mày gái thì nó
không vui bọn kia nó sẽ thoát game sớm
thì phải gái sớm
anh vẫn lỗi này the f*** xem nhé
cho tôi à Ừ chị bắt mỗi cho nhập 22 đi
I
eat Index bằng bằng khác
ừ ừ
U22 kìa con tí đi lại phải bắt cho nó 22
sổ đỏ thì đài ngày dòng đầu tiên là biết
được ngay mà đây
Thời đại này em ạ
à à
U22 đúng nhỉ
em vừa nhóm hay hay mà
Anh khác hay hay
Ừ Vậy tí weather
and play
đang ai à
à à
Có ai có mặt ở
à à Index của nó lại vào 13 chưa đồng Ô
được rồi bởi vì có nhiều nhóm bị bỏ qua
đi back nó có thể khác
à à
Ừ ừ đúng rồi 22 còn là bởi vì cái cái
thứ tự của cái này nó còn từ số 1 đầu
nữa à
chú chó ra được rồi giờ mình sẽ thử
Singapore cái này sport này hình như
mình bị ghi sai bị ngược Đấy Hình như là
phải ngược lại sẽ máy
Ừ đúng rồi tôi bị nước làm chỉ tăng
cái này kiểm tra cái này cái thì ra tôi
khó chịu của VP để mà lúc mình không
biết rồi Thằng này phải nặng bạn lần
trước là đằng sau tôi dùng pp tôm mà nó
có gợi ý còn dùng cái khác không gợi ý
rồi quên mất
đấy nha với mỗi hàng 22 tối cho mày ông
xem nhé chạy được
như này ạ
xin lỗi này
xin lỗi này là lỗi xác không phải lỗi
Liên Quan của tôi nữa
khi quét thuê bổ khách hàng
có gì ạ
Ừ cái lỗi cú pháp vãi chưởng à
Ừ tôi bắt ông trễ đấy
Sao lại xóa xóa đi
xe khách hàng
haussmann Họ tên Lỡ đâu nhỉ
Ừ
cái này lỗi cú pháp của của ông đấy Đúng
không Nó là tôi thấy thế mà à
à à
em
xem có cái notap thôi cho bỏ qua ông ấy
xuất file là sai rồi không phải lỗi của
tôi đấy
à à
ở Facebook bao nhiêu
Ừ đúng rồi Thế bây giờ code mình thành
hoàn hảo rồi à
xe
chạy thôi đúng không
ý đồ rõ ràng là lỗi cú pháp bên mình đi
ngồi sửa của Phát người ta không đúng
không ạ mình sẽ phải bạn bác người ta tự
làm lại chứ
ở những Cười cái gì nhỉ bây giờ trong
trường hợp với ông ấy em sẽ xử lý nha
không ạ Mua sữa từng cái một thôi kệ đi
em
ở cách để mà sửa Bắc đi nữa
ở đây đây Béo lỗi cái lại lỗi cú pháp
đây lại lỗi liên quan cái gì mấy ông
import-export Tao đây còn gì alo
họ đậu xanh
Ừ không sao có đừng Linh sự xóa nhé nhé
ừ ừ
Ừ đúng rồi Sao tôi là cái Lung Linh chứ
ờ ờ
ừ ừ
sau đó Xóa hết gần như ở hết sạch pha để
xóa rồi sẽ không còn bất nữa
mọi người Các bạn cứ bị làm sao ấy Ừ
Ừ chắc lỗi cú pháp là mình vẫn bỏ qua mà
chẳng qua tôi đang lấy nó ra thôi Tớ là
II lỗi ra để mấy ông thấy tôi có lỗi thế
tôi mà tắt cái loại này đi mày không
khách mời ông biết được Tại sao bị lỗi ô
ngọn núi nó ra để mà mình bắt được
trường hợp cho em mà lỗi do cốt của mình
hay là lỗi do cốt của mấy ông đấy nhưng
chắc chắn vô rồi lỗi cốt cho mấy ông đấy
rồi ông ạ thì
cái ca Vừa rồi tôi xóa cái file 2 file
này đi hơi sai đúng ạ Đã nãy mình lên
đổi nó qua ích và mình không in lỗi đẩy
ra nữa cũng được thôi tôi lỡ xóa rồi
Thôi cứ inbox lại vào đây đã kể
Em có nhớ bắt ông ấy inbox lại phải phải
export lại chuẩn là được đây 22 mình là
32 đúng không Thế là xong lại hai ông
hai nhóm mày có vấn đề cả nhóm 19 nữa
đấy khi con nhóm nhóm này nhiều file quá
bỏ qua đấy nóng inbox cho sản lỗi cái
này Nhìn là biết không có gì không khách
không lỗi được
à à
Ừ nếu nhìn What the f*** report 4 file
này à
chắc chắn à à
anh không hiểu nhỉ import ra mà cái tôn
gì rồi không biết em nói chung à Mấy ông
ấy không quan tâm được Nếu mày import
nhau mình đi post vào không được thì bắt
mấy ông ấy phải import export lại nói
chuẩn thôi
Ừ
rồi có gì mình sẽ xem chai lại nếu mà có
vấn đề gì nữa phát sinh không ạ
à à
I Nếu lại đổi tại tp má mì của tôi Tôi
hơi mới nhé tôi tôi tải cái này nó xuống
ngay từ đầu năm nay đấy
anh ạ
Anh ấy nói chung là mấy ông thấy qua
việc là hôm nay tôi để mô cốt các thứ
thứ đến không thấy qua việc là đúng rồi
nếu anh ấy hình export là export Dạ nhà
lấy từ tôn nào ấy hôm qua nhóm mình xin
của nó qua tôi ở đây tu nào chứ không về
từ hẳn nó Tâm bây I
Ừ từ cái xô đồ gì để mà ra được câu truy
vấn ở ông ấy copy không chịu thằng đấy
anh nói chung à
Bây giờ tôi vẫn chưa chấm được cái gì cả
bởi tốn hơi nhiều thời gian sẽ làm một
cái thùng xe chưa trả mua cái gì cả nhớ
thì thôi sẽ
những nhóm là đang xem trực tiếp được
không ạ thì tôi sẽ còn tinh những cái
nhóm này nữa để mình nhỏ mới cập nhật
lại người ta ra đây cái sau đó thì
tôi sẽ chậm nhận cái nhóm trước mắt như
thế này đã tôi xem qua xem thêm sửa xóa
cũng những nhóm mình như nào
Thế là tối nay tôi lại mất buổi tối ơi
trong cái đó Sếp vừa nhắn có cái Bắc gì
đó ở bên this song Sếp đang định gọi
trực tiếp này anh hỏi 8 buổi không thấy
đã kết thúc từ đây rồi nhé
tu này tuần này tôi sẽ không chia sẻ ở
đâu Cho dỡ hàng tôi đi Cốc Cốc cơ như
tôi sẽ không chảy đâu
hả lỗi ở cái con kia đúng không thôi
không quan tâm mấy ông in export kiểu gì
mà người khác không biết bó được đấy lỗi
của ông bởi vì cái này giống khách hàng
với cái hàm các bạn gửi sản phẩm với
hành khách hàng phải sẽ được dù sai bất
kỳ một cái nhỏ nhất hay to nhất khách
hàng không quan tâm họ sai là sai đúng ạ
Các bạn sẽ phải sẽ phải xử lý những cái
điều đấy
hôm bảo vệ đồ án là thế tôi không quan
tâm việc mấy ông chỉ cần thường mà rồi
chấm hay thiếu một dấu chấm phẩy xài vẫn
là sai thế nên là mấy ông phải chắc cú
kiểm tra hết tất cả mấy cái đấy đã
em đừng để đến ngày hôm đấy rồi nó bắt
đầu kéo nền đà ăn mấy hôm về sẽ gắn đây
nhá Tôi sẽ không có tí thân thiện thì cả
rồi nó sẽ gặp tôi sẽ không cười cất nhà
được nói chung lúc nghiêm túc thì sẽ rất
nghiêm túc
đấy ông sẽ nói chung là thế thì mày ông
mới thấy được đây nó sẽ như thế nào đúng
không ạ
Bởi vì tôi là người tôi là người dạy mấy
ông mà tôi là người chấm thì rõ ràng là
thường người ta sẽ nghĩ tới khiến vị
đúng không Không hề Thiên Vị Bất Kỳ Ai
tôi cũng sẽ mắng là chơi như bình thường
để chị ạ bất kỳ ai luôn à Ừ Ok bữa mai
tạm kết thúc ở đây Thôi nhé
Ừ có gì toàn bộ mấy câu hỏi hôm nay tôi
chưa trả lời được thì tôi sẽ tổng hợp
của sao trả lời nha sẽ chào bạn nhé
ừ ừ